en la ciudad de sealed las calles se han
convertido en ríos la gente está
luchando por salir adelante con el agua
hasta la cintura y las casas inundadas
desde hace varios días las lluvias
torrenciales e incesantes caen sobre el
noreste de bangladesh en pocas horas
pueblos enteros han inundado habitantes
aislados que el ejército intenta evacuar
según las autoridades más de cuatro
millones de personas están varadas
algunos intentan salir ellos mismos
arriesgando sus vidas más al sur en la
ciudad portuaria de chittagong varios
residentes han muerto por
desprendimientos de tierra
con
batasuna
las fuertes lluvias también están
afectando a la vecina india en el estado
de assam el brahmaputra uno de los
mayores ríos de asia ha roto sus diques
inundando 3.000 poblaciones los
servicios de emergencia están
desbordados
hemos rescatado y evacuado a casi 150
personas y traeremos de vuelta a otras
50 que están actualmente ahora
en esta región el monzón provoca
regularmente inundaciones según los
expertos el cambio climático está
aumentando su gravedad y frecuencia
es la tercera vez que nos enfrentamos en
lund acciones esta vez la inundación
sumergió completamente en las calles
todo lo que se reparó después de la
segunda inundación está de nuevo en
ruinas
sin la visión de la ley
y es probable que la situación empeore
todavía se esperan fuertes lluvias en
los próximos dos días